JUDGE JEANINE: WELCOME BACK TO
"JUSTICE."
BE IN * USING A GLOBAL PANDEMIC
AND ECONOMIC CRISIS TO PLAY WITH
AMERICANS MONEY.
AND A GOVERNOR PICKS A FIGHT
WITH THE SENATE MAJORITY LEADER.
JOINING ME, KEVIN McCARTHY.
CONGRESSMAN THANKS FOR BEING
HERE.
I SAID IN MY OPEN 4.4 MILLION
PEOPLE HAD TO GO ON UNEMPLOYMENT
THANKS TO NANCY PELOSI’S DELAY
OF 7 DAYS WHEN THERE WAS ALREADY
AN AGREEMENT ON THE CARES ACT
WHEN SHE WAS PITCHING FOR
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AND THE
KENNEDY CENTER AND THE GREEN NEW
DEAL.
WAS I WRONG?
>> YOU ARE NOT WRONG.
THAT ONE IS JUST LAST WEEK.
WHILE SMALL BUSINESSES SHUT DOWN
AND MADE THE SACRIFICE TO KEEP
AMERICA HEALTHY, NANCY PELOSI
SACRIFICED SMALL BUSINESSES.
SHE HELD IT SOME WHEN THERE WERE
700,000 SMALL BUSINESSES WITH
APPLICATIONS BUT THEY WERE OUT
OF MONEY.
NANCY PELOSI OWES THE AMERICANS
AN APOLOGY.
SHE’D HELD UP EVERY SINGLE BILL
WHEN IT CAME TO CORONAVIRUS.
THE SECOND TIME SHE HELD IT UP
FOR THE ENTIRE WEEK TO GET MORE
FUNDING FOR THE ENDOWMENT OF THE
ARTS, THE KENNEDY CENTER.
THEN SHE CAME BACK THIS TIME, WE
ASKED TWO WEEKS IN ADVANCE.
WE SAVED 30 MILLION JOBS.
4.4 MILLION LAST WEEK WAS NANCY
PELOSI’S UNEMPLOYMENT SHE ADDED
TO AMERICA.
JUDGE JEANINE: THAT’S ABSOLUTELY
STUNNING TO ME.
BUT I WANT TO MOVE ON.
THERE IS SO MUCH GOING ON WITH
RESPECT TO THE MONEY THAT IS NOW
BEING ALLOCATED.
BUT MOSTLY FOR AMERICANS WHO ARE
OUT OF WORK AND SMALL OF
BUSINESSES OBVIOUSLY.
BILL MAHER AS I SAID EARLIER IN
THE SHOW ASKED THE QUESTION,
WHAT DO YOU DOW DO JUST KEEP
PRINTING MONEY?
SHE SAYS THIS IS LIFE AND DEATH.
BUT WE ARE AT THE POINT WHERE
SOME OF THE STATES ARE SAYING
LOOK, IN ORDER FOR TO US GET
BACK ON OUR FEET, WE NEED THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO GIVE US A
CLEAN SLATE.
SO IF WE ARE INDEBTED BECAUSE OF
THE MEDICARE SYSTEM THAT WE
DON’T MONITOR PROPERLY, I WOULD
SAY, AS WELL AS STATES THAT HAVE
PROMISED PENSION BENEFITS TO
GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEES, THEN YOU
ARE GOING TO HAVE STATES THAT
ARE FLUSH PAYING FOR STATES THAT
HAVEN’T BEEN ABLE TO MANAGE VERY
WELL LIKE NEW YORK, NEW JERSEY,
ILLINOIS, MICHIGAN.
AND ANDREW CUOMO REALLY WENT
AFTER MITCH MCCONNELL.
>> WHAT I SEE IS THE GOVERNORS
WHEN THEY DIDN’T PLANNING THEIR
OWN STATES, THEY LOOK AT THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GRAB MORE MONEY.
IF THEY WOULD LOOK AT WHAT WE
ALREADY PASSED.
WE PASSED $2.7 TRILLION, AND
ADDED ON WITH WHAT THE FED IS
DOING.
THAT’S $7 TRILLION INTO THE
ECONOMY.
WE SHOULD ALLOW THAT TO GET UP
AMENDMENTED.
THE LIBERAL DEMOCRATS WANT MORE.
IN THE LAST MONTH WE PROVIDED
MORE THAN 500 BILLION DOLLARS TO
THE STATES.
WE SPENT ROUGHLY $600 BILLION
FOR AN ENTIRE YEAR WHEN IT COMES
TO MEDICARE.
WE HAVE $150 BILLION GOING OUT
TO THE STATES BY THE END OF THIS
WEEK.
WE INCREASE WAD WE PAY WHEN IT
COMES TO MEDICAID.
CITIES BIGGER THAT 500,000 GOT
DIRECT MONEY INPUT.
REMEMBER WHAT GOVERNOR CUOMO
GOT.
HE GOT HOSPITAL BEDS, NAVY
SHIPS, VENTILATORS.
HERE IS PRESIDENT TRUMP TRYING
TO PROTECT US FROM THIS CRISIS
WHILE NANCY PELOSI IS TRYING TO
POLITICIZE IT.
INSTEAD OF FOCUSING ON WHAT WE
NEED TO ACCOMPLISH HERE.
JUDGE JEANINE: THE REAL PROBLEM,
CONGRESSMAN, IS THE FACT THAT
YOU KNOW, YOU SEE CUOMO DIGGING
HIS HEELS IN AND SAYING WE
MISMANAGED THIS STATE AND WE ARE
IN THE HOLE, POLITICIANS
PROMISING EVERYTHING BUT THE
KITCHEN SINK TO GET RE-ELECTED
AND THE REST OF THE COUNTRY
SHOULD PAY FOR IT.
I’M A NEW YORKER AND I DON’T
THINK IT’S FAIR.
>> IT’S NOT FAIR.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SPENT
$500 BILLION.
WHAT WHEN MADE TO DO NOW IS FIND
A WAY THAT WE NOT ONLY OPEN UP
THE STATES IN A HEALTHY MANNER
AND HE STATE IS DIFFERENT SO YOU
FOLLOW THE DIRECT AND YOU OUT
ALL AT ONCE.
BUT WE NEED TO OPEN THE OTHER
ESSENTIAL THINGS LIKE CONGRESS.
THAT’S WHY I SENT A LETTER TO
SPEAKER:PELOSI THIS WEEK, WHERE
EVERYBODY VOTES IN A POCKET BY
PROXY, LET’S OPEN UP THESE
COMMITTEES, THE NATIONAL DEFENSE
AUTHORIZATION.
OR OVERSIGHT LOOKING AT THE
W.H.O. WHICH I THINK SHOULD BE
RENAMED WITH THE DIRECTOR THEY
HAVE NOW AS THE WUHAN HEALTH
ORGANIZATION.
THESE ARE THE THINGS WE SHOULD
BE INVESTIGATING TO KEEP AMERICA
SAFE.
JUDGE JEANINE: AT LEAST START